often thought this that the left is very
good at slogans you know March forward
into the future you know and if you
think what a slogan would be on the
conservative side it would be something
like hesitate you know um and um that
doesn't work when it comes no I I I I
once saw an example of that that one of
the only protests I've turned up to I
remember uh years ago and I was with a
friend of mine from Northern Ireland a
few of us and I can't remember what
protest was but at some point we we sort
of all chanted something and then we
stopped we sort of did it once and I
said to one of the friends we're not
very good at this are we and she said
well Douglas we we our view is if you
said something once that's quite enough
and